In the situations where a database is involved and we have to be concerned about
transactions, that is making sure that the data that we store and
retrieve is consistent with respect to
the overall database we have to deal with transaction processing, and
in particular with what are called the ACID properties. The primary concern is
reliable database access, particularly when there are multiple readers and
writers. That is parts of the application reading from the database and
other parts writing into the database, particularly on in addressing
a particular, a specific record. Imagine that you were in a situation,
maybe you were doing airline reservations or something like that,
and you need to understand the information in the database, but
you may want to update it if you're making that reservation. Okay? So
you have to read it, examine it, change it, and then write it back.
What happens if another application changes the record after you've read it,
but before your change version has been written back. So we'd like to have
database transactions that satisfy the ACID properties, and ACID is an acronym.
The A stands for Atomic. That means that your transaction, these four steps,
reading, examining, changing, and written, are all treated by the system as if
they were one step with no intermittent activities going on. The C stands for
consistency preserving, in the sense of database integrity. Okay. That is
if the database satisfied all its integrity constraints before your transaction,
it will also satisfy them after your transaction. Third, the letter I stands for
isolated. Okay, that, what that means is that other transactions can't see
into any intermediate states in the processing of your particular transaction.
And finally D stands for durable, and
that mean that once your transaction commits then it's persisted.
That means it, it is a permanent record that the system is aware of.